this right here is a GoPro Hero 5 today
we're gonna put this in the center of a
car tire and spin it really really fast
and see what kind of crazy images we can
get how crazy you might be asking let me
show you here it is so this is a GoPro
that's spinning really really quickly
crazy and a certain point it starts like
syncing up with itself like almost to a
point that like the spinning rate
matches the rolling shutter rate so you
can actually end up seems kind of like
how when you're going on a freeway and
tires look like they're going backwards
it's just syncing up with the refresh
rate of your eyeballs this is a raw
image from the camera not edited after
the fact this is exactly how the camera
captured it like what's this the reason
why you're getting this really crazy
weird artifact here is this effect known
as rolling shutter Destin from smarter
every day has a fantastic video
explaining what this artifact is and how
sensors work but basically you have a
video and it's say 30 frames per second
well one of those frames is also
recorded over the course of time from
the top to the bottom a single frame
from a video is actually recorded from
the top and then like a millisecond goes
by it record a little bit more another
millisecond goes by of course a little
bit more and then over a few
milliseconds it records the entire image
that is so fast that for most of the
time it appears like a solid static
image but if you have something that's
spinning really really quickly it like
rotates through that and it creates
these really weird artifacts as you can
see in Dustin's video what I wanted to
do today was figure out how we can
recreate this sort of super fast
spinning and see if we can get any sort
of artifacts similar to what we're
seeing in this video so in the past we
have done some pretty crazy rig the
GoPro 2 cannons
[Applause]
we go front of sword videos but today I
specifically want to do something
jankier and quicker probably just gonna
put this in a case and gaff tape it to
your car tire isn't that gonna be a
problem when we started going really
fast I hope not I mean maybe
do you have hubcaps for wheels there's a
difference I don't know if you have nice
wheels
you don't need hubcaps I guess we'll go
see backfired oh that's the big one is
the a380 Billy like you're playing like
airplanes that's a big one kind of food
do you like to eat on airplane Billy I
think I'm gonna try to shoot 2.7 K at 30
frames per second for it to be perfectly
centered for the the lens it needs to
mount right there okay you ready no
return after this sticky stuff sister
peel it off and then wait how do how do
I do that
Wow I'm a tape of master I built an
entire two-story fort out of cardboard
using just ran I've been taping since
day one dude I was taping since before
you were born you can't be bad if the
sticky part fails will this tape be
enough to hold it there go prone attire
oh you suck O'Brien era that's not
coming off that is excellent you're not
relying on the stickiness you're relying
on the strength of the tape yo we can
talk about tape all day or we can take
it to the streets
you can't go wash my hands real quick No
is this on tape this guy over here
Harley is kind of worried but the other
part of me is like no my tape Jonas
Wallace
and once you've done a full rotation you
have officially gone 80 point 7 inches
I'm trekking with 7.6 miles an hour
that's exactly 100 rpm the closest I can
do is just keep it right in between five
and ten which is basically seven oh
what's up man should we bring street
meat guy to do these experiments with
this dude hang a grill down our street
wearing a robe girl some food she we
experiment with Streamy guy we put a
GoPro on the tire I noticed that that
was like a little thing that was given
out over there fifteen miles an hour
all right and the GoPro is still there
you're so good we haven't lost the GoPro
yet see how fast you can go just get as
much speed as you can fly off the bridge
so at 60 miles an hour that was 785
revolutions per minute so we got up to
700 85 RPM on the gopro well we want to
hit a thousand first let's review the
footage we can take I could fall asleep
I can live here great in this position I
have to go to the bathroom we're about
to watch some footage that could trigger
epileptic people into a seizure so or
anyone you want to mount our I can't I
can't look at it
[Music]
see that is like ready okay now on the
bridge this is when you're picking up
the most feet
[Music]
we're forming it into almost one plane
we need to go faster though we don't
know how fast we have to go for it to
sync up because if you don't actually
know what the 88 miles an hour well we
can go out on the highway and try to go
as fast as we can
I didn't see what happens this is Phase
two we did a first test which actually
worked out really well once we got up to
like 60 miles an hour something strange
happened and we want to see if we can
recreate that that means we got to go a
little bit faster we're gonna go the
speed limit I don't know what that speed
is I mean here in LA you can go like 85
miles an hour without being worried
about getting pulled over that's just an
Los Angeles fact we're gonna go right
after the speed limit and no faster just
wait it is rolling what speed we had
from my face okay now try to hold at 70
just like Cruz at 70 we got our data
Nick so you you held it going 80 for a
bit and then you managed to get it up to
90 for a little while like 65 what I'm
hoping is that we actually reach a level
of harmonization with the framerate and
the spinning speed firetruck I'm hoping
that we'll get some stabilization in the
camera itself oh yeah sent you one yeah
he did I was no longer jealous many
other thing it only makes you sick when
your eyes can somewhat track it okay if
you're going slow enough that faster
speed you can't track it yeah Oh start
to go the other way again but yeah you
see how crazy that curve is that's
because of the rolling shutter whoa whoa
okay we're getting up speed something's
happening
something's happening so 70 was what is
this look at that it captured part of
the ground in the one frame at the top
but then by the time we got down to
halfway through the frame it was now
recording it at the bottom
whoa dude you're seeing the truck upside
down and right-side up in the same image
[Music]
so weird and cool it's okay oh okay now
it's cool
huh okay 1040 775 916 rpm that's the
speed at which you need to spin the
GoPro for the rolling shutter to sync up
with the horizon I was hoping that we'd
get it perfectly like every frame is
like say every frame the ground is here
that's the case you'd have to be going a
hundred and forty miles an hour so it's
like every other frame is the ground
perfectly because it's like it syncs up
right here you can see the spinning of
the horizon this start to slow down and
then it's stuck right here but we're
still getting the flashes back and forth
let's play through it at normal speed
this is normal speed it's a little too
jarring here at normal speed but playing
in at fast forwarded speed because it
matches up when you're playing a fast
forward speed is dropping that one frame
so in theory should get pretty smooth
and it does it does get smooth so you
don't have to go 140 miles an hour you
just have to double the speed of the
footage so yeah this is this is way cool
right 2x speed than 1x speed that is so
sweet dude yes
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]